this video is brought to you by swedish
pod 101
pod 101 courses are one of my favorite
ways to start learning a new language
online
click the link in the description for a
free lifetime account to give it a try
hello everyone welcome to the langfocus
channel and
my name is paul today we're going to
focus on the swedish language
the svenska spruckett in swedish or just
svenska swedish is spoken by around 10
million people mainly in sweden where
it's the native language of around 8
million people
and also in finland where it's the
second official language after finnish
with around 270 000 native speakers
it's a continental north germanic
language which is closely related to
norwegian and danish and is mutually
intelligible with them to some extent
the degree depending on the dialects in
question
like all north germanic languages
swedish is a descendant of old norse
which developed from proto-germanic by
the 8th century
over the next 600 years or so old norse
developed into the various north
germanic languages of today
old norse first diverged into old west
norse
in norway iceland and the faroe islands
and old east norse
in sweden and denmark old east norse
then divided into old danish and old
swedish by around the 13th century
old east norse is sometimes referred to
as runic swedish and runic danish
even though they were basically the same
until around the year 1100
this name comes from the fact that it
was written in the runic alphabet
specifically the younger futhark
alphabet the latin alphabet was adopted
in sweden around 1225
due to the christianization of sweden
and this marks the beginning of the old
swedish period
later that century the hanseatic league
began to arise
it was an alliance of middle low
german-speaking trade communities
spread out across the baltic region and
scandinavia including the major
cities of sweden through its domination
of trade over the next several centuries
and through the settlement of
aristocratic families from what is now
northern germany
middle low german had a significant
impact on the vocabulary of swedish
swedish also became simpler in its
grammar as it developed from old swedish
to modern swedish
it originally had a more complex case
system four cases rather than the
current
two cases three genders rather than the
current two genders
and a more complex verb system the
printing press and the publishing of a
swedish bible in the 16th century
the gustav vasa bible marked the
beginning of the modern swedish period
the gustav vasa bible was a major step
towards more standardized orthography
but it wasn't until the 19th and 20th
centuries that swedish became more
uniform
due to migration and urbanization and a
standard language was created
by the time of the spelling reform of
1906 swedish was almost the same as the
contemporary swedish in use today
today standard swedish dominates
throughout sweden in general and most
people are fluent in it
regional dialects are still widely
spoken though they are not quite as
distinct as they once were because of
the influence of standard swedish
the main dialectal difference today lies
an accent
let's examine some of the features of
swedish focusing on standard swedish
there are 29 letters in the swedish
alphabet 9 of them vowel letters and 20
of them consonant letters
but those letters represent more than 29
distinct phonemes
the vowel letters represent pairs of
short vowels and long vowels
with short vowels appearing before a
long consonant that means
two or more consonants and long vowels
appearing before a short consonant
meaning a single consonant or before a
vowel or at the end of a word
in most cases the long and short vowels
are also different in quality not only
length
for example this word has a long vowel
gloss
and it means glass this word has a short
a vowel
glass and it means ice cream this word
has a long vowel
boot and it means cure this word has a
short vowel
and it means staid standard swedish has
no phonemic diphthongs
though some dialects such as the scanian
dialects of southern sweden do
some consonant sounds are represented by
digraphs
these digraphs all represent the sound
as does the letter j
as well as g before front vowels these
digraphs all represent the sound
as does sk before front vowels otherwise
it's pronounced sk
these digraphs represent as does k
before front vowels otherwise it's
pronounced k
and sometimes ch which is used in
loanwords
this digraph represents at the beginning
of words and
in other contexts this digraph
represents
and these digraphs represent retroflex
consonants the retroflex element being
shown by the r
in each digraph the standard sound
represented by
r is a voiced alveolar trill and in some
words an alveolar tap
but this is one sound that differs
depending on the dialect
with some southern dialects of swedish
pronouncing it as a uvular trill
or as a voiceless or voiced uvular
fricative
the letter g is normally either
pronounced ga like a hard g
or ye before front vowels it's never
pronounced
ja like the soft g in english like
norwegian
swedish has pitch accent a shift in tone
on the stressed syllable
like in norwegian there are two tone
patterns tone one
is a rising tone the pitch rises on the
stressed syllable
then falls on the unstressed syllable
that follows
tone 2 is a falling rising falling tone
the pitch falls on the stressed syllable
then rises and falls again
on the unstressed syllable that follows
many pairs of words can be distinguished
based on their pitch accent
here's an example in tone 1
meaning the book and in tone 2
meaning overripe or spoiled regarding
fruit
tone 2 normally appears in words with
multiple syllables and
inflection aside from the definite
article tone 1
normally appears in words with only one
syllable and words with the definite
article attached
the n in booken is a definite article
this means i read the book word for word
it's i
read book the swedish word order is svo
as in english the only difference here
being the placement of the definite
article
the definite article takes the form of a
suffix in swedish
and its form depends on the gender and
number of the noun
modern swedish at least in its standard
form has two genders
common gender and neuter gender for
singular common gender nouns the
definite article is usually
n or after a vowel
the definite article for singular neuter
nouns is
however the final t is usually silent in
most accents
unlike the definite article the
indefinite article comes before the noun
n for common nouns and
for neutral nouns how about for plural
nouns
indefinite plural nouns are formed by
adding indefinite suffixes
which differ depending on the noun's
ending
places for plural definite nouns in the
common gender you add
na to the indefinite plural
for plural definite nouns in the neuter
gender you add
ah to those ending in a vowel and you
add
n to those ending in a consonant the
places
this means he doesn't drink coffee word
for word it's he
drink not coffee again this sentence is
svo
with one difference from english syntax
the negation marker inte
comes after the verb rather than before
it and also
notice that while english has the
auxiliary verb do
here in the form doesn't swedish has no
equivalent of that
if we make the sentence affirmative it
shares the same syntax as its english
translation
he drinks coffee han is the third person
singular personal pronoun
swedish has a system of personal
pronouns similar to that of english with
a couple of differences
there are second person plural pronouns
which are also used as formal second
person singular pronouns
there are also two equivalents of it in
english one for common gender
then and one for neuter de
and there is also a controversial gender
neutral pronoun
hen this is not a pronoun that arose
naturally in swedish but it was
constructed in order to replace the use
of masculine pronouns
in context when you are not specifically
referring to a man or a woman
you know in english i might use he or
she in such a context
some people accept this pronoun and
others reject it it isn't widely used in
speech
but it's sometimes used in writing and
on tv
does he drink coffee yeah at home yes he
does
as you can see from this question in
swedish it's very simple to form a yes
or no question
you simply move the verb to the front of
the sentence
does he drink beer earl is a cognate of
the english word
ale no he doesn't
the most common way to answer yes or no
questions is to first say
ya or nay followed by de then a verb
followed by the pronoun then the
negation marker inter
if it's negative in many cases the verb
is a form of
which means do for each verb tense there
is only one
form of the verb it doesn't change
depending on who or how many people are
speaking
so in the present tense it's i do
do yar you do he does
etc in the past ten sets yeah you would
die i did
do you would they you did honey you were
dead he did
etc in the future it's
i will do
he will do etc obviously this makes
verbs easier to use than in many other
languages
i've never been to norway word for word
it's i have never been in norway
this is almost word for word the same as
the english sentence
except that e translates as in rather
than two
this sentence features the present
perfect which is formed in a similar way
to its english equivalent
notice that i said similar not the same
here we have the auxiliary verb
the present form of the verb ha which
means have
over here we have a form of the verb
meaning be
in english we use the past participle
but in swedish
it's a different form called the supine
and there's a different past participle
form for other uses
notice also that the adverb aldrig comes
between the two verbs
why not means why and is a cognate of
the archaic english word
wherefore which you may know from romeo
and juliet
wherefore art thou romeo which doesn't
mean where are you romeo
like most people think it does it means
why are you romeo
as in why can't you be from a different
family but i digress
beer is more expensive in norway than in
sweden word for word it's
beer is more expensive in norway than
in sweden it almost translates directly
into english
except for the way the comparative is
expressed in english there are two
comparative forms
first with the er suffix and second with
more before the adjective
with most two-syllable adjectives and
all adjectives with three or more
syllables
in swedish it's similar with single
syllable adjectives taking the suffix
are and adjectives with two or more
syllables being preceded by
mir in this case the english word
expensive has
three syllables so it uses more while
the swedish word
has only one syllable so it takes the
ade ending
one more thing to note here is the verb
it is the present tense conjugation of
the verb
meaning to be is the infinitive form
it developed from old norse vesa then it
became
vera then it became the english verb to
be
in all its different conjugations
developed from two different verbs
old english baeon and old english weisan
which is cognate with the swedish word
superlatives
what's the biggest city in sweden word
for word it's which is
sweden's biggest city here we have the
question word
vilken meaning which next we see svarius
as i mentioned earlier swedish used to
have four cases
but now it only has two the nominative
and the genitive
which is shown with an s at the end of
the noun similar to how apostrophe s is
used in english to show possession
next star is the superlative form of
stur which means big just like swedish
has comparative forms that partly
resemble the english ones
in this case bigger it also has a
superlative form that partly resembles
the english one
star is like the est ending in english
but this one might not be the best
example come to think of it because it's
irregular most single syllable
adjectives take the ending
most expensive the form with the e at
the end
aste is used when the adjective is
definite
particularly when preceded by a definite
article or genitive pronoun
multi-syllable adjectives form the
superlative when mest
comes before them like english most most
intelligent
would be mist intelligent the rules
about single-syllable words and
multi-syllable words are not 100
in fact this word could also be said
with ast rather than
messed but the rule is generally true
swedish stored in stockholm the biggest
city in sweden is stockholm
word for word sweden's biggest city is
stockholm
stockholm gothenburg isn't as big as
stockholm
word for word it's gothenburg is not
like
big as stockholm comparisons of equality
are formed in swedish by using
plus an adjective followed by some
literally
equal adjective as
is a cognate of english like in its use
as an adverb
you are as tall as ella word for word
you are equally tall as ella
you may be getting the sense that
swedish is quite similar to english in
its grammar and to some extent in its
germanic vocabulary
english-speaking learners of swedish are
often struck by just how similar the two
are
and by how intuitive swedish is for them
the bigger challenges in learning
swedish seem to lie in the pronunciation
in the early stages and in getting used
to dialectal variation and different
accents in the later stages
but all in all people who learn swedish
overwhelmingly enjoy the process
and their efforts are well rewarded the
question of the day
for speakers of swedish to what extent
would you say that you speak
standard swedish and to what extent do
you use your local dialect
and to people who have studied swedish
what has your experience been like
what have you found easy and what have
you found challenging if you're excited
to learn more swedish then click the
link in the description to visit swedish
pod 101 or
visit langfocus.com swedishpod
it's one of the most extensive swedish
courses i've ever seen with literally
hundreds of lessons for learners of any
level
and the lessons get progressively more
challenging as your level improves
as the name suggests they're podcast
based lessons which is great for people
who like to learn using audio materials
and for people who want to learn on the
go these days i try to focus much more
on audio materials than i used to so
that i can repeat new words and phrases
to improve my pronunciation
and at a more advanced level i shadow
entire dialogues or monologues
but pod 101 courses offer more than just
audio lessons
they have lots of video lessons as well
as downloadable books and pdf
materials so that you can get visual
input and explanations of all the
language introduced in the lessons
they also have audio recordings of the
individual words and phrases
so you can review them individually and
you can create vocabulary flashcards
that use spaced repetitions to help you
memorize the words more easily
they also offer quizzes to help you
review the lessons word lists of the
most commonly used words
and other features now the biggest
problem most learners seem to have with
innovative language courses is that the
lessons are
short so they make the mistake of
breezing through them too quickly and
moving on to the next lesson
but i really recommend that you slow
down and you practice what you learn in
each lesson before moving on to the next
one
you can listen to the lesson multiple
times review the lesson transcript and
notes
use the flash cards and test yourself
either by yourself
or using the system's built-in quizzes
that's where the real learning takes
place when you reinforce and review what
you've learned
i've never learned a language using only
innovative language courses but i'm a
member of several of their sites and i
regularly use them as part of my study
program
lots of content is free including all
new lessons which are free for the first
couple of weeks
and then if you want to access all the
content you can upgrade to a paid
account
i really recommend you check out
innovative languages courses
whether for swedish or one of the other
33 languages they offer
click the link in the description to get
a free lifetime account
i also want to give a big shout out to
all the langfocus patreon supporters
especially the top tier patrons whose
names are on the screen
check out patreon.com langfocus and
check out the benefits of the various
tiers
and everyone thank you for watching and
have a nice
[Music]
day
[Music]
you